تحظى الخطط الاقتصاديه الكبرى التي
يتبناها المرشحون لانتخابات الرئاسه
التركيه باهتمام كبير من جانب الشعب
التركي وذلك في الوقت الذي شرعت فيه
البلاد في التركيز على المشروعات
الاقتصاديه التي من شانها ان تضاعف الناتج
المحليه الاجمالي وتزيد من فرص العمل
وترفع الصادرات التركيه الى مستويات
قياسيه كما يسعى هؤلاء المرشحون الى الحد
من انخفاض العمله والسيطره على التضخم
الذي بلغ مستويات قياسيه ترشح الرئاسه
والرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان يسعى الى
حسم المشكلات الاقتصاديه الكبرى التي تعصف
بالبلاد
ويتضمن برنامج الانتخابي الامور
الاقتصاديه التاليه
رفع حجم التجاره الخارجيه لتركيا الى
تريليون دولار خفض معدلات التضخم الى خانه
الاحاد
تحقيق معدل نمو اقتصادي سنوي يبلغ خمسه
ونصفا في المئه زياده الدخل القومي الى
تريليون ونصف تريليون دولار خلقه سته
ملايين وظيفه جديده خلال خمس سنوات خفض
معدل البطاله الى سبعه في المئه تعزيز
الاستثمار والترويج للقطاع السياحي وذلك
بهدف الوصول الى 90 مليون سائح
مضاعفه الاستثمارات في قطاعات الطاقه
والزراعه والتعليم والنقل
اما زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري كمال
كاليجدار اوغلو فيركز برنامجه على الاتي
جلب استثمارات الى تركيا بقيمه 123 مليار
دولار في السنوات الخمس الاولى
تعزيز تنافسيه الاقتصاد التركي عبر تعظيم
الانتاج والتصنيع عالي الجوده رفع دخل
الفرد تدريجيا ليبلغ 20 الف دولار سنويا
تحقيق معدل نمو اقتصادي في حضور خمسه ونصف
في المئه على الاقل في السنوات الاربعه
الاولى القادمه
توفير مليونين ونصف مليون فرصه عمل جديده
في السنوات الخمس المقبله
بالانتقال الى السنان اوغان وهو من تحالف
الاجداد التركي فيركز برنامجه الاقتصادي
على الاتي رفع الحد الادنى للاجور الى ما
يعادل 1500 دولار تعديل قانون الضرائب
لزياده موارد الدوله تجاوز النموذج
الاقتصادي الحالي القائمه على بيع
العقارات وتاجير اراضي الدوله تحويل تركيا
الى مركز تكنولوجي متقدم لجعل البلاد
مركزا دوليا لانتاج الرقائق الالكترونيه
تحسين ورفع معدل الوظائف للمواطنين
الاتراك
الاقتصاد سيكون العامل الاكثر حسما على
الارجح في انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه وذلك
بينما يخافون على مكاسب تحققت على مدى
عقدين من معدلات النمو المرتفعه وبين من
يتخوفون من استمرار تراجع الليره وارتفاع
معدلات التضخم